there was this great thread that this  dude put up on Twitter where he said how  do you think the intelligence agencies  react to severing everyone from their  grid they've got they've got  um big facilities that wiretap the the  internet cables that go through the  undersea cables Elon puts them all on  his satellite Network and now they've  got to come to him and he controls the  single access point to spying well  that's dangerous we shouldn't have it no  individual should control the actual  points of communication yeah but they  but the intelligence agencies do every  undersea cable you think they're not  tapping that data I think they are they  absolutely are or they're trying to and  maybe maybe we're all sitting here like  oh Elon so great we're showing free  speech and what he's really doing is  making an excuse to centralize  Communications so that a single point  for everyone in the world to have all  their data collected and tracked